we begin with a fox news alert tonight
tonight we are more than one month into
putin's bloody invasion into ukraine and
yet russia's murdering thug has almost
nothing to show for his efforts except a
lot of dead soldiers faltering economy
blood all over his hands because of the
brutal indiscriminate bombings that have
destroyed hospitals and schools entire
cities and neighborhoods almost the
entire city of mariopol but look at your
screen early this morning a port city
occupied by russia in southern ukraine
was rocked by explosions now in a major
blow to putin's navy one russian warship
was obliterated look at that
and other two
the other two were visibly damaged now
this was during a ukrainian strike now
the vessels in the process of warrant in
the pro the process of unloading
important supplies they were meant for
russian soldiers fighting on the front
lines make no mistake ukraine is
shocking the world very few people
including myself thought that they would
be able to hold out for more than a few
days and now there is a distinct
possibility if they get the proper
support they could actually win this war
against russia and putin but a big but
they need joe biden they need nato
allies to provide the weaponry to
actually win this war of aggression
let's stop russia right here in ukraine
right now now again i want to be very
clear i'm not talking about one american
foot on the ground no boots on the
ground that cannot happen biden needs to
adopt the reagan and trump doctrines as
we have been discussing and nato and joe
biden need to do two very important
things and they need to do it
immediately one
they've got to get president
zielinski and ukraine all the weapons
they need as fast as possible that means
the drones middle and long range air
defense systems the javelins stinger
missiles and yeah joe next time if
poland wants to give a migs don't veto
that let the migs go to ukraine so they
can fight the war themselves two europe
needs to stop importing russian energy
oil and gas right now any country that
continues to buy any of vladimir putin's
oil or gas is funding his war and yes it
especially includes germany which is
still very reliant on russian oil and
gas now if only germany had some warning
about the dangers of their dependency on
russian energy
oh wait
they were warned by president trump a
few years back you might remember
i think energy is a much different story
than normal trade
and you have a country like poland that
won't accept
the gas you take a look at some of the
countries that won't accept it because
they don't want to be captive to russia
but germany as far as i'm concerned is
captive to russia because it's getting
so much of its energy from russia so
we're supposed to protect germany but
they're getting their energy from russia
explain that and it can't be explained
you know
trump was right again germany did not
heed that warning and now they are
funding the bloodiest most destructive
war in modern european history never
underestimate germans the german
germany's ability to screw up their own
backyard but today during a press
conference in brussels one german
reporter wasn't interested in asking a
question about the war in his own
continent instead he offered biden an
opportunity to bash donald trump and his
supporters on the world stage which of
course joe happily obliged
i had no intention of running for
president again
and until i saw
those folks coming out of the fields in
virginia carrying torches and carrying
nazi banners and literally
singing the same
vile
rhyme that they used in germany in the
early twenties or thirties i should say
i say to people at home
imagine if we sat and watched the
uh the doors of the bundestag broken
down and
police officers killed and hundreds of
people storming in
or imagine if we saw that happening in
the british parliament or whatever how
would we feel
and
one of the things that i take some
solace from
is i don't think you'll find any
european leader
who
thinks that
i am not up to the job
you're not up to the job he's the
weakest and worst president we've had in
the modern era and joe while he's in
europe he's more than happy to wax and
wayne about a 2017 riot in
charlottesville virginia uh but somehow
he can't seem to answer a simple
question about deterring vladimir putin
watch this
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
you know yeah one final question right
halo way hold on a second please
i was supposed to be an hour ago at the
european union meeting and to speak now
i'm thanking you
so someone i haven't called on before
you
who are you i'm christina
okay
sir deterrence didn't work
what makes you think vladimir putin will
alter course based on the action you've
taken today let's get something straight
you remember if you covered me from the
very beginning i did not say that in
fact the sanctions would deter him
that's not what i said you you're
playing a game with me i know the answer
is no
i think what happens is we have to
demonstrate the purpose the single most
important thing
is for us to stay unified
that's what you suggested to what kamala
harris said now joe's answer on the use
of chemical weapons also failed to
inspire any confidence take a look
so you've warned about the real threat
of chemical weapons being used have you
gathered specific intelligence that
suggests that president putin is
deploying these weapons moving them to
position or considering their use and
would the u.s or nato respond with
military action if he did use chemical
weapons you know on the first question i
can't answer that i'm not going to give
you intelligence data number one number
two
we would respond we would respond if he
uses it the nature of the response would
depend on the nature of the use
allow me to translate joe biden has no
idea how he would respond to a chemical
attack now he and nato better figure
that out fast considering they're the
ones that keep telling us uh this can
happen the world needs strong decisive
clear-minded strength and leadership
especially from the united states but
it's not going to come from that guy
because biden is sadly unwilling
mentally unable to provide that kind of
leadership sad but true instead
according to general jack keane who will
join us in a moment biden is now
pressuring according to high-ranking
sources of his president zielinski to
make a deal with putin to surrender to
give in what give half your country away
joe is that what you would do surrender
you know oh okay you invaded us i'll
give you i'll give you california idaho
and uh oregon we'll even throw in new
york appease a murdering thug
dictator that invades a foreign country
is
is that your idea of appeasement boy you
make devil chamberlain look like winston
churchill now back here at home biden
has no plan at all for our 40-year high
record inflation or the all-time high
gas prices all of us are suffering under
and now a looming food shortage which
according to
2020 joe biden a food shortage is a sign
of failed leadership that's what joe
said in 2020 take a look with regard to
food shortage yes we did we
still talk about food shortages
and uh and it's going to be real we
don't have a food shortage problem
we have a leadership problem
we have plenty of food
leadership problem is you joe ask
yourself could biden's presidency could
it get any worse
the economy in this country is awful we
are absolutely headed towards
inflation a recession inflation's at a
40-year high joe
gas prices are at record high prices
it's killing the poor in the middle
class and every american pays more for
every item they buy in every store
thanks a lot it's costing everybody a
hundred bucks plus to fill up their gas
tank it's costing more to heat and cool
our homes a nationwide food shortage now
in the looming uh of course the border
uh in a state of chaos all created by
joe all preventable if he would have
kept donald trump's policies in place
biden's afghanistan withdrawal an
unmitigated disaster he turned the page
and people are trapped behind enemy
lines that's great by the way the
taliban announced that girls can't go to
high school joe you going to do anything
about that there's a massive new war in
europe china is threatening to invade
and take over taiwan iran has never been
closer to getting nuclear weapons even
worse biden is sucking up to how
humiliating to this country the the
muellers in iran he's sucking up to the
murdering thug dictator of venezuela
he's begging over and over again even
though he keeps getting rejected opec to
produce more oil but according to joe
america is back and better than ever joe
biden is delusional hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else